so we're both old enough how do you
remember the original Bladerunner being
received
oh I remember hearing I was too young to
see it that summer it was 80 early
eighties yeah anyone or something like
that so I'm 14 and I had heard from a
cousin of Mines father that it was like
it was okay it wasn't as gross as alien
but it was pretty good but in 85 when I
moved into Manhattan from Tarrytown one
of the here in New York yeah one of the
first no Manhattan Beach one of the
first things that kid was my my my
friends took me to see Blade Runner for
my first time at the Waverly theater and
the first 10 times I saw it it was like
a do Waverly of the heat that's a
sentence you have in your the first of
the 10 times I've seen it that's a
sentence that I'm a runner over a
hundred times absolutely do you just
have bad memory
what's your hi what's the motivation
it's different every time
oh okay so here's what I want that
you're so here's my question okay cuz I
think about it but clearly you think
about this more all right maybe I think
Blade Runner I don't think the world was
ready for the cerebral 'ti of that
original boy right totally think you're
right about that
you know they had some action scenes but
it wasn't about action there was about
ideas it was about consciousness it was
about what is and is not alive yeah and
I think in the day you go to see science
fiction to just have some fantastic
story take you somewhere else well think
about all the movies that were coming
out around that time right we have Star
Wars and we have Battlestar Galactica
and we have Close Encounters all these
more rosy and bubblegum dreams of
science fiction and Ridley Scott comes
in and does alien and Blade Runner and
most dark very wood dank yeah thank
totally I mean in LA and dirty or just
by watching the scenes in that original
blame you felt like you had to go bathe
after you just witnessed it because it
was so dank and dirty and still
there's no better version of a dystopic
future that's been put with veracity on
screen than Blade Runner I submit like
those effects shots are the best ones
that I've ever been done so so that's
why they've kind of went the point I'm
getting at so I don't want to say so
much that it was ahead of its time
but it was representing a genre before
that genre really had a public
widespread following well you've had a
fair say no it's totally William Gibson
one of the three fathers of cyberpunk
along with Neil Stevenson I love it you
know you know where these names of
people run okay sterling William Gibson
one of the three pillars of cyberpunk
which is of genre that came right out of
Blade Runner believe Gibson credits
Blade Runner with inspiring him to write
the short stories that would eventually
inspire him to write Neuromancer and the
Neuromancer trilogy and that kick starts
a whole genre of fiction so you get
placeholders so good so it triggers a a
wave of creativity mm-hmm inspired it
births is honor how about that where
where could things go wrong how could
all of this abundancy that we're
creating with technology bite us in the
ass and by the way Deckard's totally a
replicant he's totally a replicant
remind me this other thing aren't we
already in the future of the year that
Blade Runner was supposed to take place
No 2019 yeah we got to close but isn't
there date I mean it's got that it's
November 2019 is what the opening title
on the Hades landscape mm cause I
remember Wow 2019 right that is like
forever from now no meat you are
thinking yeah what's what's good we're
gonna be a flank my watch is gonna make
dinner right right right right a little
cool so this next layer I haven't seen
it yet but it's of course on my list and
you've seen it have you seen it a
hundred times yes you have access I do
I've seen it twice already damn it's
okay looking forward to it it is it is
every bit as deep as the original Blade
Runner and in a totally different and of
course it's derivative and it but it has
the advantage of knowing that there's a
there's a genre and a following of that
genre that's ready to embrace it
yeah well and I think Villeneuve Denis
Villeneuve the director who directed
Sicario and arrival is has a unique
ability to weave in these really I sort
of literally allegorical themes into its
movies and I like kept on watching Blade
Runner I'm not gonna give any spoilers
but watching certain things characters
would do Blade Runner the new one the
new one whether were 2049 it's almost
literary in how much metaphor is going
on between the characters between the
characters in there you don't want too
much metaphoric because then it becomes
self-aware yeah absolutely yeah and this
one stays on a very basic level okay
cool it's lovely so long dude okay the
day I ever see a movie my hundredth time
I'm calling you yes so what is the movie
that you can't not keep watching if
you're flipping through the channel oh
the plenty like Ferris Bueller's Day Off
okay
you can't channel surf past that okay
but you can't channel surf past past
Back to the Future right and the movie
I've seen the most is the matrix oh yeah
totally
no I think there's one of course yeah
actually Anna matrix is better than the
other two matrices no way am i killing
matrices are you allow Lorelei's matrix
that way yeah yeah so I I know the
movement I mean every scene every word
gesture every it's so beautiful your
fighters oh yeah when I Fishburne
looking up a chair to see the helicopter
those hands are behind right right right
I'm not like right right all that power
I showed my son Apocalypse Now a couple
weeks tonight so how did your son 18
does he sing wonder thing - this was
thing - okay because you know thing -
came out of the box before thing one did
did you know this oh I've always been
going in the order of arrival no no no
they're right there I'm on that on in
the book thing - came out before that I
believe you're the first one to get
pedantic with me about dr. C I'm just
telling you me pay attention
no because there's a rhyme that required
that thing okay right I forgot exactly
but it's something like he the cat
wanted to have some fun first came thing
- and anything whoa wow it's a beautiful
rhyme and I think he had the rhyme yeah
and then forced him to do that to make
the ride so I in my in my reality thing
one came out first so you messed up I
did okay
Big Jim is watching he's watching
Apocalypse Now and I let it go about 20
minutes and I said you know who clean is
no Laurence Fishburne he was like what
yeah yeah as a skinny little kid yeah
yeah he lied about his age at the time
because he was too young to be in that
role and playtime movie I love that in a
heart of darkness where he talks about
how like he got to it when I got in the
movie this mom had to fly in Kings ass
you like that you want to hear more Adam
Savage chatting with Neil deGrasse Tyson
click here or go to Startalk all-access
comm / Adam and Neil for another
exclusive video we're letting you watch
that one for free too so check it out
right now